à genoux les mains derrière la nuque au
rond point de la place du 30 octobre ce
matin une posture symbolique pour
dénoncer les arrestations de la veille à
mantes la jolie
on se met à genoux on apporte notre
soutien on montre qu'on n'est pas
d'accord avec ça qu'on peut pas mettre
plein de lycéens à genoux les mains
derrière la tête comme si ils étaient
tous coupable de quoi que ce soit en
fait c'est pas possible on peut pas
faire ça au milieu de ses élèves du
lycée du castel quelques professeurs
choqué eux aussi j'ai appris ce matin ce
qui s'est passé en à mantes la jolie et
je pense que c'est la honte de la
république attaque ça s'efface sur l'arc
de triomphe
mais qu'est ce qui est fait sur la
jeunesse c'est inadmissible une mise en
scène condamné sur twitter par le préfet
il parle d'une provocation tout à fait
inapproprié à l'heure où les forces de
l'ordre font face à des attaques d'une
violence inacceptable au lycée
montchapet le blocage n'aura été que de
courte durée
dès l'arrivée des policiers les élèves
grévistes laissent les autres rentrer
dans l'établissement
c'est compliqué de deux d'être crédible
dans ses revendications si c'est juste
pour [__] la merde partout en fait et
on peut pas empêcher pas la liberté
c'est aussi ne pas empêcher les gens qui
veulent aller en cours de l'encours
surtout qu'ici à des collégiens et on a
pu on est pas du tout là pour les
empêcher d'aller travailler de se sentir
en sécurité il s'y lie les cortès des
différents lycées se retrouvent place de
la république puis défilent dans les
rues dijonnaises jusqu'en fin de matinée
hormis quelques poubelles brûlées peu de
débordements mais assez pour que les
manifestants renonce un nouveau défilé
l'après midi lundi prochain lors d'une
assemblée générale interlycées ils
décideront de la suite à donner à leur
mouvement